>>> TONIGHT VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
DRAMATIC MILITARY RECRUITMENT
EFFORT IS SOWING CHAOS.
A PROTEST MOVEMENT, MASS ARRESTS
AND A MASS EXODUS TO NEIGHBORING
COUNTRIES.
>> Reporter: AT RUSSIA'S
BORDERS, VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
COMEUPPANCE, THE LIFEBLOOD OF
HIS WAR IN UKRAINE,
MILITARY-AGED MEN FLEEING FEARS
OF CONSCRIPTION.
RECORD NUMBERS CROSSING INTO
NEIGHBORING FINLAND.
>> BASICALLY THE RUSSIAN INFLOW
OF PEOPLE HAS NOW DOUBLED IN THE
COURSE OF THE LAST FIVE DAYS OR
SO.
WE ARE NOW ALREADY IN THE
PROCESS OF BASICALLY SQUEEZING
THE INFLOW.
>> Reporter: GEORGIA, ANOTHER
BORDER RUSSIA'S WOULD-BE
RECRUITS ARE RACING FOR.
CARS ARE BACKED UP FOR TENS OF
MILES, AND A TWO-DAY WAIT.
THEY DON'T NEED A VISA, BUT EVEN
SO, RUSSIA SLOWING THE EXODUS TO
A TINY TRICKLE.
SOME PAYING TO JUMP THE LINE
BEFORE A TOTAL FEARED EXIT BAN
RUMORED FOR SEPTEMBER 27th.
>> Translator: IN THREE HOURS WE
JUMPED A 40 KILOMETERS, 30-MILE
LINE.
IT'S NOT A NICE THING TO DO, BUT
ALAS, THE 27th SCARES ME
GREATLY.
>> Reporter: HE ADDED, THE
BORDER GUARD CALLED ME A
DESERTER.
INSIDE SIBERIA, A VIOLENT TURN.
AT CLOSE RANGE, A MAN SHOOTING A
RECRUITMENT OFFICER.
OTHER WOULD-BE RECRUITS SCATTER,
RUN SCREAMING FROM THE ROOM.
THE OFFICER WOUNDED, TAKEN TO
HOSPITAL.
A MOSTLY MUSLIM REGION OF
RUSSIA, POLICE FIRED OVER
PROTESTERS' HEADS, OTHERS
WRESTLED TO THE GROUND.
ANGER PARTICULARLY STRONG HERE,
AS MANY RESIDENTS FEEL
RECRUITMENT FALLS TOO HEAVILY ON
THEIR COMMUNITY.
PUTIN'S FABLED ABILITY TO READ
RUSSIA'S MOOD APPEARS TO BE
FADING.
HIS OWN OFFICIALS ADMITTING
MISTAKES WERE MADE.
THE CHAIRWOMAN OF THE FEDERATION
COUNCIL OF THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION SAYING OFFICIALS
OVERSTEPPED TO TAKE SUCH
LIBERTIES IS ABSOLUT